okay this is new yes okay
so the thing is
they have no coordination
i mean one guy loves staffer one guy
thinks it's a stupid opening
and that both
actually
so that means we alternate moves yeah
three plus two
uh it's me and grandmaster shrinov
narayanan
um link below to his youtube channel
we're playing against aliban and dina
valencia
okay good luck
yes
yes
okay let's go
so
you choose the opening
well there is no opening apart from e4
oh yes of course let's go
so
do we go crazy or
uh we go the positional indian school
what is an indian school i mean
it's kind of hard to resist
i can't resist okay
yes and um he's one of the biggest
supporters of our chess uh streamers
front page
and he prepared me with this
beautiful idea beautiful idea of
number three uh
number seven c3
there's also this guy eric rosen who
prepared me with some amazing staff
regular crap
yeah and i think the last one that i got
this morning was d4
yes so they're doing the same thing
absolutely and now we're
[Music]
again oh my god
i think i will get tired of stafford
soon all right so my mother was bishop
e3 in the movie the game against eric i
guess we're not allowed to discuss
though yeah i don't know yeah so just
make anymore but you can ask him
questions yeah you can do anything
[Music]
it was not the kind of question
that's my good right
yeah i was not expecting that i mean he
talks a lot about nonsense but even he
was surprised by that yeah
oh like
yeah i was so taken back by that
question you really wanted to answer
yeah and i was like okay what answer for
this room
i think yeah if eric can't sacrifice his
peace
you cannot play sir before he starts to
fall oh
bishop
oh it's better to jump from this place
later in my previous game i played it
always okay but then i thought look at
it okay so fine
development first yeah sure
oh yeah guys it's it's also possible to
play stafford without losing everything
you have
[Music]
oh is it it's a nice life lesson
so we're doing our best um we're so
strong together i don't even know if i
should uh start the only traffic
i mean
yeah yeah you can do it i think it's
more fun
what's your favorite oh no let's play
fast actually
yeah
but you should keep asking them
questions no no we need to learn more
about eric yeah i will ask you like
how did you guys need me and eric yeah
um so we're having dinner with kevin and
another thing
i embarrassed myself already
i know then when was this
this was when you were still
in the competition
ah okay here yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
always yeah all this happened how did
you meet anything
uh yeah it's a long story yeah we don't
want to get with you
yeah we don't care
interests
i can smell the fear oh such a beautiful
home
yeah i like it
i can stand loudly
yeah i would wonder what would grammy
say about stafford i think would be very
disappointing
it's mine right yeah i think it's time
to make our dreams come true yeah yeah
exactly now that we're here
which is already a dream
okay this was
very good oh what a beautiful okay now i
have such an amazing your ponds are
about to yeah yeah they say oh yes
that's the one yes because the other one
maybe it gives some chance but this
looks beautiful yeah those should go to
the center yeah i think after this game
probably yeah he could not play staff
okay
oh no the bishop do you know what the
rule says
whenever you have opposite colored
bishops you need to attack the king
yes this is exactly what i did against
though you should listen to her oh my
god you should have listened to me
okay
yeah yeah okay it's all fine it's all
fine we repeat we repeat once and we see
how it goes
life is good
we don't need to get cranky
oh this is a mistake this
okay
oh
what kind of juice is that is that
carrots
i don't know what it is not every year
i think it's easy wait carrot juice is i
think it's easy
you just made it control that's it this
is what you think yeah yeah just
maintain control oh yes that's exactly
what i wanted see this is how you made
it
this is how you create friends yes
and see now they are losing control yeah
oh no we are being full on vdvd
yeah keep maintaining your control
yeah okay that's um
i would have preferred yeah
what did you mean by this no just uh now
just
okay
wait what
that part comes later
it's like oh no my queen oh oh my god
i love your style
wow
okay what a move
i let gentlemen decide on the floor
on the position
i also had this idea you know
[Applause]
wait what's that yeah that's megan
just make anything yeah we already know
queen arbiter
well you're so good at counting that
that's fine whoa what a sacrifice but
this is now still wait why did he take
the bishop
the king
i'll just like pass over
yeah yeah
yeah i will do that
oh yeah yeah just keep it keep it simple
like this all good
boom
do you know that there are ways that
this decision oh yes this is what i
wanted
stoppable tonight
that's my cocktail over there let's do
it oh the thing is
that
[Laughter]
time
but we weren't you bought goods we
fought goods yeah yeah you were playing
against world champions yeah yeah that's
like
outlast and outmatched
your talk was better than ours